Hi! !uickly, before Ms coffee Bean comes:
If you already watched our
video about the Charformer,
go away… there's nothing you can see here.
Oh, here she comes...!
Hi, what is tokenization?
You know, that line of code you use from
Huggingface Transformers and never care about.
In today’s video, we will see how this works!
Tokenization is that part in
pre-processing that is done to text
before throwing it into your
favorite language model, say BERT.
It’s a pre-processing step, so it is
independent of the later training process,
but it's crucial for most transformers.
Without tokenization, each word of the
English vocabulary would have to be
assigned a unique vector on the input side
and, when predicting the masked word in
the output, the choice would have
to consider the whole vocabulary.
And if you believe that the English vocabulary
that one can find in a dictionary, is already
huge, think about how it can grow even faster
with all words that are not in a dictionary,
like compound words created on the fly by someone
as a stylistic figure. Or all possible typos,
right? A mistyped word is also a word and should
have a way to be processed by a language model.
This is where tokenization comes in, to
at least partially, solve this problem
by creating a smaller vocabulary of
word building blocks. This hopes to
cover as much of the dictionary as
possible, including unexpected words.
Therefore, tokenizers first segment the sentence
into words (harder for some languages than for
others, looking at you, Chinese, Thai and Korean,
because you do not have whitespace separation).
Then the words are parsed into sub-words, so
that even though supposedly the dictionary does
not have the word “pre-processing” in it, and
therefore no vector representation to associate
with it, the tokenizer can divide
the word into “pre” and “processing”,
supposing that “pre” and “processing” are already
in the vocabulary and have a vector association.
And this works great in very regular kinds of
words that can be decomposed into known blocks,
but does not solve the problem of noisy text, full
of typos where the possibilities of mistyping are
so many, that a fall-back to a known subword is
either impossible or leads to misunderstandings.
So tokenization, being so rigid can become
a problem, an even bigger one when working
with multiple languages where the
out-of-vocabulary problem becomes
even greater with every additional
language the model has to handle.
Even more, the downside of tokenization is that
on downstream applications, you are kind-of
forced to use the same tokenizer as the model
was trained with, because the trained model is
very much dependent on the tokenization
it is used to. Even though your task might
benefit from other tokenizations, you
now must stick with the initial ones.
No, you're not allowed to see
other tokenizers, Ms. Coffee Bean!
Well, we hope that we could make the purpose and
inner workings of tokenization now clearer to you.
Do not forget to like and subscribe!
Okay, bye!
Hey, so it's me again. As you have perhaps
already noticed, this is a partial reupload
of the explanation of tokenization we
did already in the Charformer video.
We think we did quite an OK job at
explaining it there very general,
but that general explanation is not search engine
retrievable, if you search just by "tokenization".
So through this video, we just wanted to
resurface that explanation a little bit.
And that was it.
Okay ... How does Ms. Coffee
Bean usually end these videos?
Okay, bye?